my name is Barry Dayton my presentation
will be representations of algebraic
plane curves
okay so let's get started here so we'll
jump right to it sir right to the
advertisement okay I have Wolfram Media
has just published this book of mine
this actually came out this week
and I want to talk about it or they want
me to talk about it there are various
ways you can get this book you can go to
well Wolfram media Wolfram - media.com
or the shortcut here is Wolfer am that
am dating curves get you right to their
their site and they have links then you
can get it as a Kindle book for about
$35 this is is $50 however since most of
you have Mathematica available probably
this this free zip file which has the
chapters as individual notebooks but
indexed so you can go back and forth
that's free from the Wolfram media site
so you don't really have to pay for this
if you don't really want to tackle this
whole three hundred and forty page
document there's a nice short version in
the mathematical journal at Mathematica
journal calm and you can get that also
in PDF or better yet in notebook form
and then you can manipulate it so that's
also available if you do that and then
you really want a chapter i'll have
individual notebooks
on my my own website Barry age datin dot
space and go to there I already have a
few Corrections and I will keep that
those notebooks up to date and and so on
[Music]
okay this is this is kind of left out an
important word in the title here that
this book covers plane curves I am
working on a sequel to this which will
do space curves but right now you just
have to go to my website too if you want
to see how far I've got again I've got a
summary but it's only about half written
okay so an algebraic plane curve is is
like a it's a solution set of a
polynomial equation like this one it
could have integers as coefficients or
it could have in this case these are
really rational numbers as decimals or
it could be the mathematical machine
numbers and exactly what that solution
space is is something you have to read
about actually in the Mathematica
journal version the this version
unfortunately they actually left out
that paragraph unfortunately but
basically what we're saying is if you
use n solve or find root any output will
give you a point on the curve and so we
can start out
I'd say trying to yelps no it doesn't
work here on this computer
let's see how bad no it didn't work
to a whole thing I'm sorry about that
okay this is their computer yes okay
okay well there's a little error here
but that's okay what we okay so what
happened here though is I have this
equation
besides the polynomial itself called f1
I put another little poof polynomial
function in there and then solve these
two simultaneously and I got seven
points forget the stuff at the end here
we'll come back to those seven points so
those are points on the curve and this
is my big day this is the big difference
between what I'm doing and say algebraic
geometry where curves don't actually
have points because they're only allowed
to use rational numbers as points
coordinates but I can use floating point
I can use a machine numbers so we
actually have points okay and I can then
wait oh I know what happened is I didn't
get this first okay let's go into the
next page okay well the next page okay
the next page I talked a little bit
about what I mean by an infinite point
an infinite point is a triple that is
the end of a line
and both ends of the line have the same
if at a point the first two coordinates
of the triple give you the slope or the
direction vector and the third
coordinate of an infinite point is zero
I will see as we go on okay let's try
this again here okay so let's see I'm
okay I have a little general program
which finds what I call critical point
so this is a ok what I really want to do
with this polynomial FY is I want to see
what the graph looks like I want to see
what this looks like okay that's what I
want that's my main goal and I'm
basically what I'm gonna do in this talk
is give you four ways in which we can
actually look at what this curve looks
like once it's we also add the infinite
points so okay let's try this here there
we go okay so here I have the so-called
critical points and oh I need the
infinite points that was back two pages
ago way down here
there okay I have to run this okay there
are infinite points right there and
notice they and their triples ending in
zero now let's go to where we were and
we'll get a nice picture of that so
we're gonna actually make a an
association or a rule that allows to
these various points so we can plot them
nicely and so there's my association and
now I'm gonna go to the next page
and okay so here's my contour plot I can
make a contour plot okay so the critical
points are numbered one through seven
and the black numbers and you can see
why I call them critical points because
they're kind of important points where
this curve is is turning actually
they're giving maxims omit or local
maximum local minimum of the distance of
the points from the origin these are not
intrinsic points of the curve but they
are positional points and then the
orange numbers are the infinite point so
they're not where I put them but they're
at the end of those lines and notice how
the same point is at both ends so both
points called nine are essentially not
quite but essentially at the end of the
x-axis whereas the points mark 10 are
essentially at the both ends of the
y-axis and they the points mark eight
are at the end of that kind of slanted
line which is parallel to the line x
equals y and so it has the same infinite
points parallel lines meet at these
infinite points okay so my first
represent
nation is a grass in the sense of a
grass and in Mathematica and here we go
okay so in this case our graph consists
of two circuits two cycles here and if
you kind of look up here the first one
say starts with with 0.67 the upper left
and then it goes to 0.9 now say 9 is out
here so we started 6 and then 9 is our
infinite point next to 6 it's also the
same 9 over there so then it goes to 1
which goes to 8 and 8 goes to that other
8 up on top which goes to 4 that goes to
point 10 which is also the point at the
bottom and goes back to 6 so this this
graph gives that those connections and
then the graph at the bottom are those
little black those critical points in
that that little loop which I guess you
start with 2 and then you go to 7 and
then you go to 5 and 3 and then back a
tube now any non singular curve is
actually going to its graph is it going
to be a disjoint union of these cycles
and this gives us what I call my
fundamental theorem plane projective
curves and that every projective plane
curve can be
fully described by a graph where the
vertices are the critical and infinite
points and the edges correspond to an
arc between the vertices the key thing
here is that every such graph is what's
called an Euler graph and an Euler graph
is a graph where every vertex is even
that is there if you count the number of
edges going in plus the number of edges
going out it's always an even number
okay that's the key thing if it's a
connected Euler graph is known as an oil
Irian growth and that's a standard thing
in graph theory now if you have this
graph you can actually fill it out and
get the curve by something called path
tracing I discussed that extensively in
chapter 4 the book I don't have time to
get into that conversely if you don't
know what the arcs are but you do know
the critical points and if it of points
then there are ways to try to figure out
where the edges are it's a little bit
slightly harder problem but the book
attempts to do that okay the next my
next representation is the idea of a
hemisphere plot hemisphere plot actually
if you google it as a standard
representation of the projective plane
basically what I do is I use our tangent
function to shrink the plane to the
inside of a disk in this case of radius
3 R and then the empty circle bounding
that disc is the infinite line and the
interior is the normal what we call a
fine plane and then we can oh a good way
to see this is I'm going to plot
and this hemisphere model a collection
of lines parallel lines of slope 3 and
let's see what happens here
I get this picture and you can kind of
see why people might call it a
hemisphere although some of the people
actually use actual hemispheres but this
is why it's called the hemisphere plot
and notice that all these point all
these lines go through the same infinite
point and that infinite point is of
course at both ends plane so that's
here's some here's another example of
hemisphere plots I have I have this
curve and if I take the contour plot
it's not very interesting it looks like
this
and it doesn't even appear that this
plot satisfies my fundamental theorem
because they it seems to have four
different asymptotes that aren't
connected and that's not what my theorem
says it says that you're gonna get up
you're gonna get an Euler graph that
always comes around any they follow any
path you'll get back to the beginning
but this is the hemisphere plot down
below and what we see in the hemisphere
plot is in fact this curve has two
infinite s-- as tangent to the infinite
line in two places and the end of the x
axis it actually hits the infinite
lining comes back and the y axis it is
actually the infinite line is a is an
inflection point so it actually crosses
it but it's tangent to it so the
interesting part of this curve is that
infinity and that's a nice reason to
have this this model okay my
the nicest model is what I call that
it's maybe a span model again this is a
fairly standard model see if I have here
a maybe expands to see how this works
here's a maybe expand what I do well
it's easier to go backwards so I I pick
say a little line which will be
essentially my negative y-axis I cut
there and then I follow this midline
around a hemisphere and and then when
I'm done what I have is just a long
strip so it may be as band as meso if
you reverse that what I just did put it
back together again this long strip
folds into the maybe expand okay so the
picture here is the the ratio here
between the 2 X and y axis is quite
different because it's supposed to be a
very long skinny strip but what we have
here is the upper half plane is on 1/2
the lower half plane is the other half
we're kind of doing this by basically
using going to pull the coordinates and
the infinite line actually it goes
around twice on the top the whole bottom
line which correspond with the original
hasn't been mutilate the whole boundary
goes to zero to the origin they call
gets squashed to the origin
if you don't like that you can think of
the interior of this long strip as being
the ordinary a fine plane but in polar
coordinates but bounded polar bounded
like in the hemisphere plot and and
we're missing the origin so if you take
the plane without the origin that gives
you you're a fine okay your ordinary
plane or you can actually think of the
this as being the ordinary project a
plane with those tiny disk remotes
their various models you can you can use
here okay so here are some pictures of
what this looks like there's a the first
one there's two lines two parallel lines
they meet that dotted line is the
infinite line they meet on the infinite
line a hyperbola has two infinite points
and so they connect on the infinite line
three circles the black circle goes
around the origin so it actually goes
kind of all around a by the outside edge
so it goes around twice but the other
two don't and so they're just kind of
circular or oval shapes and then the
bottom one is the irrational function
and I drew each branch a different color
and you can see that we have two
infinite points one at the end of the
x-axis
and one at the end of the y-axis and the
purple ones go between those two and the
other let's see if I can now there we go
well this isn't okay anyway uh I'm gonna
go but you can manipulate that okay so
the final thing though I have to tell
you about our final representation this
is called a diamond diagram and the
diamond diagram comes in two varieties
one is the where we actually use the and
a first quadrant we actually take the
sign of the coefficients and if the sign
is positive it's a green point if it's
negative it's a red point and so the
point at say I J is X is the sign of the
x to the I Y to the J term then there
are some ways of extending this to the
whole picture which is then supposed to
be a picture of the whole projective
plane with the x axis the y axis and the
outside is the infinite axis and
basically this tells us that we can have
one crossing of the y axis the curve
could cross actually one or three times
the positive x axis and negative y axis
can have zero or two crossings and
they're going to be zero or two infinite
points in the sort of the positive
infinite line which means the
coordinates are the same sign and we
have to have one in the negative one so
this gives us actually quite a bit of
information about the curve and that's
really just Descartes rule of signs
nothing more complicated than that so
that's useful but the other
representation with diamond diagrams is
more an attempt to kind of model a
region plot but over the entire plane
including the infinite parts and here it
shows where the function itself is
positive or negative and unlike the
first one which just sort of constrains
the curve this is an actual
representation of the curve in other
words a left-hand one we see there the
three positive components the curve is
going to cross the positive x axis
exactly twice there's going to be one
positive and for the point there's going
to be one negative infinite point and
it's going to cross the negative X's
once it's not going to cross the
positive Y axis at all but we'll cross
the negative y axis three times so that
gives us then sort of a representation
of what this curve is going to do so
these are the ways that I can once I
figure out what this curve is I can
represent it in any one of these three
ways or several of these three ways and
then I can understand what this curve is
doing as a as a real projective curve so
of course if you want to find out more
you can get this book or you can
download you know books for free either
from my side or from the Wolfram site
welcome Mediasite and you can find out
all the details so I think I'll stop
here cuz my time is running out and I
know that's not the way we do it at this
conference we bent over but I will
actually finish on time so any questions
thank you